[Musique]
un gigantesque incendie vient en effet
d'éclater en fin d'après midi les images
sont extrêmement impressionnante le toit
est en feu et la flèche vient de
s'effondrer c'était un ami perez jose
car de bronze
un énorme panache de fumée visible
pratiquement dans tout paris notre dame
est en feu le monument le plus visité
d'europe l'un des symboles de la
capitale française
voici sa flèche qui culmine à 93 m brûlé
par les flammes elle vient à l'instant
de s'effondrer l' incendie s'est
déclenchée peu avant 19 heures il aurait
pris dans les combles de la cathédrale
et s'est étendue à la charpente en bois
du monument construit entre le 12e et le
14e siècle
impossible pour le moment de connaître
l'origine exacte du sinistre mais les
pompiers privilégie un accident des
travaux de réfection sur le toit de
l'édifice sont en cours depuis cet été
un important périmètre de sécurité a été
mis en place de nombreux secours
arrivent actuellement dans le 4e
arrondissement
la maire de paris marie anne hidalgo
déplore un art terrible incendie sur ce
site classé au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité depuis 1991 c'est l'image de
la france et c'est un symbole c'est que
du dans le monde entier 14 millions de
visiteurs chaque année c'est vous savez
aussi c'est une longue histoire ça fait
partie de notre quand on parle de
patrimoine on se rendra compte la
charpente ce sont des arbres qui ont été
qui ont été plantés il ya mille ans
c'est cette charpente a été construite
au début du xiiie siècle jamais elle n'a
été touché par un incendie
c'est une forêt on l'appelle la forêt
cette charpente et de voir ces images de
notre dame de paris en flammes c'est
quelque chose qui pour nous français et
d'assez insupportable vous imaginez ces
c'est vraiment l'image de notre pays
c'est quelque chose qui nous touche au
coeur
[Musique]
on a des températures qui dépassent les
1000 degrés et donc forcément
la structure est fragilisé et et
forcément on arrive qu'on peut avoir
avec eux d'éboulement compris sur la
structure en pierre qui est donc je les
tours par exemple
y compris sur la structure en pierre pas
sur les vertus qualité mais tu as des as
des routes qui peuvent s'écrouler si les
routes s'écroule le reste suit donc
le risque est là
pourquoi ne pas intervenir par les airs
la sécurité civile explique
hélicoptères ou avions
le poids de l'eau et l'intensité du
largage à basse altitude pourrait en
effet fragilisé la structure de notre
dame et entraîné des dommages
collatéraux sur les immeubles aux
alentours
ce soir selon le ministère de
l'intérieur sauver notre dame n'est pas
acquis
[Musique]
dans le coeur des français il y a
désormais un avant et un après 15 avril
2019 voilà ce qu'il reste de notre dame
après l'instant dit qui a détruit la
charpente et la flèche la structure a
résisté mais certaines parties sont
fragilisés des pièces exceptionnelles du
trésor ont pu être sauvés le grand
chantier de reconstruction a déjà
commencé une souscription nationale a
été lancée les promesses de dons
affluent plus de 700 millions d'euros à
7 heures emmanuel macron s'exprime ce
soir sur ce drame
bonsoir a tous une grande partie de ce
journal est bien sûr consacré aux
conséquences de cet incendie qui a été
un choc pour nous tous vous allez
découvrir les toutes premières images de
l'intérieur de notre dame on mesure
l'étendue des dégâts marc dana
premiers pas
dans une cathédrale désormais
méconnaissable
au sol le noir des poutres calcinées
contraste avec une lumière intense et
inhabituelle en levant les yeux on
aperçoit l'ampleur des dégâts
la nef est désormais à ciel ouvert
les vitraux se reflète dans les immenses
flaques d'eau laissé par l'intervention
des pompiers de vero
des échafaudages installés pour des
travaux de rénovation de la flèche sont
encore là
les bancs des fidèles sont en partie
intacte comme s'il venait tout juste de
les quitter
au loin on devine un amas de poutres
noircies
au sol un épais tapis de cendres c'est
tout ce qu'il reste de ce que l'on
appelait la forêt cette charpente
médiévale de plus de 1000 chaîne parti
hier soir en fumée
et regardez maintenant cette photo
aérienne elle résume bien l'état de la
cathédrale à l'extérieur la charpente et
la flèche ont disparu des zones entières
de la toiture sont calcinés les deux
tours ont résisté les trésors de notre
dame ont été mises à l'abri
notamment la sainte couronne benjamin de
l'ombre
le temps d'une nuit
le visage de paris a changé la partie
haute de notre dame mangés par les
flammes
sa flèche minutieusement bâti
disparu pour toujours
en neuf siècles d'histoire jamais
l'édifice n'avait connu pareille
catastrophe
[Musique]